best-selling books of all time
uh da vinci code harry potter and right
near the top is 50 shades of grey
shocking right so what a surprise yeah
like you know to the point smut is the
bible is the bible not counted in that
list i i think it excludes the bible
simply okay it's a religious text but um
yeah you like you need to understand the
the power of language and conversation
because like you said early on like the
meatball between your ears you know
sorry the meatballs in a woman's ears is
her most important sex organ uh leading
up to the event of intimacy so
don't discount it i mean uh
they dig it trust me i mean you look at
the book sales the numbers are right
there there is no lie
um well i wish we could i i get a lot
you get a lot of guys who will sort of
message me and write me and be like
i don't know if i can be that dominant
guy i don't know if i can you absolutely
can if i could you know ever do that
kind of stuff or or
i'll get guys who are like
who might think my wife wouldn't like
that my girlfriend is too pure and too
innocent and too much of a princess she
wouldn't like that
i look if if she has ever read
she's ever read any kind of romance
novel i guarantee you she has some
degree of perverted thoughts going on in
her head
like men are way more like
like horny and and want sex all the time
women are more perverted
so when the things that they want out of
sex are a lot tend to be a lot darker
and more twisted than what most dudes
are into or but what most dudes
fantasize about at least i don't know if
you remember this but i
but i put that in my book um there was a
study done i think by google engineers
on search engine habits
and um
the top search results for women looking
for uh kink you know into the dirty
toxory area i think was
um vampires werewolves pirates
surgeons and billionaires
[Laughter]
powerful men
that can do interesting things with uh
great reach yield and uh
influence so and and dangerous men too
dangerous yeah dangerous um yeah you
know
you know women love a dangerous guy that
um can be civilized you know they
they want to feel safe but they want to
know that you're dangerous at the same
time so you have to have some some dirty
side to it i i
take that a step further and i say all
the time that like
the demonstrating the capacity
i'll make that i'll emphasize that the
capacity
for violence
actually demonstrates that you can keep
her safe and you can protect her correct
because there's a big difference between
being peaceful and being harmless
those are two different things yeah this
is the jordan peterson thing peaceful
yeah like a dude who's peaceful can
actually
can is withholding his ability for
violence he has he has the ability of
violence but he's not using it i do this
harmless can't even conjure up violence
if he wanted to
and so decide
when we're tapping into these things
like being more dominant in the bedroom
being more commanding with our language
getting hurt telling her what to do in
the bedroom for example
we're tapping into that more dominant
part of the masculine
sexual energy which is what she
resonates with that's what she's looking
for because it demonstrates you have
that more dangerous side which is the
capacity to protect her and keep her
safe eventually and and her kids could
after the fact once you pregnant her
with your seed
given that the um that the podcast is
called the unplugged elephant it's based
on the book um why do you think it is
that so many
men are plugged into the notion of just
being the good guy and being respectful
and
you know not being the dirty talker you
know whereas some other guy you know
right around the corner kevin from sales
or steve from accounting whispers in her
ear one day by the vending machine when
there's nobody in the lunchroom
why do you think those guys get it and
the average show doesn't because the
average joe has been indoctrinated with
hallmark movies
the average doe has watched too many
[ __ ]
sorry just wearing the show again uh too
many rom-coms and too many yeah too many
goddamn romantic comedies like
it's
ugh even
what's that one with will smith was it
called hitch hitch that was it where he
was like the dating coach and the fat
dude like god was just simping over like
whatever whatever her name was and then
god i'm like that's a perfect example of
this
this [ __ ] narrative of like if i'm
just a nice guy long enough if i just
treat her like a princess then
eventually she'll come around no she
won't she'll completely ignore you
at
best or she'll take advantage of you and
use you for your time and your resources
and she'll shack up with with like you
said joe from accounting or whatever
uh steve's from accounting kevin's from
sales oh okay fine all right i don't
work i don't work corporate jobs
it's been a while for you did you ever
work for a job by the way i worked a lab
job
a lab job like in a laboratory yeah i
used to be i was i was an industrial
chemist for a while okay yeah so i used
to work in a lab and
well you kind of still are now now
you're just an industrial chemist on the
side you know the side with the you know
with the brain chemistry sure that's i
don't see how you made that connection
but okay
i can connect anything man i know how
the thoughts work
um let me just see if we got anything
here in the the chat that i might have
missed out because i know you gotta run
in like 15 minutes right uh i can go to
i can go to like nine o'clock okay um
i'm gonna drop the the the call-in link
for you guys as well tonight too so if
there's anybody that has questions on q
a
um we'll be able to take some of that as
well stock
well while you have a look at that i'll
keep i'll plug a few more things about
my house while while you're looking for
that so
i've snuck a few things into this course
that most guys probably wouldn't expect
in a course on dirty talking so
obviously i talk about you know how to
talk i talk about how to improve your
delivery i talk about how to get a
deeper voice i talk about
a few different frameworks that you can
use for
creating your own ideas for daily talk
as well as stealing verbatim like my own
lines that i use in the bedroom all the
time but i
there's also a couple things in here
which you might not expect and that is
dirty talk is
one it's a tool for amping up a woman's
arousal in the bedroom obviously most
people understand that but it's also a
tool for improving your own self-esteem
and your own confidence in the bedroom
because your language dictates your
belief system and if you can i mean
affirmations are a great example of that
and most people would probably be
familiar with the idea of affirmations
but if you're in the bedroom and you're
saying
these more perverted or dominant or
commanding things to a woman that
suddenly over time starts to reinforce
this self belief that you are that more
dominant
quote unquote alpha kind of guy
and i think that's a lot of goods come
to me with this question of like how do
i be more confident in the bedroom and
this is exactly how in my opinion this
is probably the fastest way to do that
is to start playing around with this
kind of language which puts you in
charge puts you in the lead in control
of the sexual situation and she follows
and does what daddy tells her to
and then the other thing i suddenly
stuck into this course is that
what the third thing that dirty talk can
do for you is re reinforce and establish
good frames in your relationship dynamic
with a woman
so for exa as an example
uh one of the things i teach i show in
this course is meet me commanding uh
telling a work telling this in this demo
clip i tell this girl
you wouldn't dare come without my
permission now would you
and she says no of course not
what the subtle frame i've just
established there
is that she does what i tell her to and
then i go on to say something like this
that's right because this [ __ ] belongs
to me
and that is another another little
subtle frame that i
own
her and i own her sexually i don't know
i own her [ __ ] and so
if you would if you wanted to
if you think if you backwards rational
or start from where you want to be like
what kind of woman do you want to be in
a relationship with and work backwards
like what qualities would she have well
doing what you tell her to
and being sexually exclusive to you
would be pretty high up on that list i
would imagine for most men
and dirty talk is a really really subtle
and fun
fun for both you and her way to suddenly
embed these ideas and these frames into
her subconscious
and so so dirt hill is a lot more
powerful than most guys realize to to
moff's point here
how much of this is a journey like is
there a storyline an arc that you bring
i will describe like future scenarios to
her
i will get i will get
i'll tap into her imagination and get
her to imagine so say for example if i
have some perverted twisted fantasy that
i want her to indulge with me
i will probably i will preface that on
you know date two or three and start
subtly dripping it into her head so that
we'll do it later on a good example of
that would be
i like girls who are bisexual
who can i can have a threesome with
right so i will i will suddenly tell
this maybe not so suddenly but i will
tell i'll whisper in this inner ear
something like imagine if i had you tied
up in that corner
and you were watching me with another
woman how turned on would that make you
and i'm saying this while i'm having sex
with her
so i'm painting this future picture of
you're gonna and i'm eroticizing the
idea of her
getting off watching me with another
woman and then her joining in with that
so i can i can has that ever turned a
straight woman by for you hasn't i
wouldn't say it's i
i think every woman is basically kind of
bi there's very few there's very few
women that are like 100
straight in my opinion
they're like they're either like
when when
dudes think they're looking for like a
bisexual chick they think they're
looking for a woman who actually has
dated like chicks before and then
there's but that's that's actually a
small subset of women and there's a tiny
subset of purely straight and then
there's everybody else in between who's
like
flexible
or at least okay is at least willing
to
share your penis with another woman
that's if that and i'm totally happy
with that extent of bisexuality if
that's all she wants to do that is
totally fine by me because i get two
vaginas right
and i mean like generally speaking most
women are receptive to this set i mean
if they have genuine desire for you
it's it's it's highly i mean you could
pull a librarian with the the hair bun
and the librarian glasses with a little
vest out of the library and think that
she's a prude but she's you know she's a
lady in the street and a freak in the
sheets
like it's it's what it's widely regarded
i think by most guys you know with any
level of experience that that almost all
women are receptive to it if it's
delivered
timely and
you know at the right degree i mean
timely is the biggest part of it all
right and you talk about the you know
when to deliver it and how to
in that course i mean i saw a few
elements in it
um
go ahead yeah i was just gonna say when
it comes to delivery like i i talk yeah
i talk about inflection and then and
keeping you you'll tone it like a
neutral or a poor breaking inflection
when you're delivering it no you don't
want to go in there and be like how are
you doing like when you're delivering
yourself you're talking about turning to
mickey mouse obviously but
that is one thing obviously a deeper
vocal tone always helps
i personally do a lot of whispering
stuff but occasionally i'll mix it up
and occasionally i'll be more commanding
and like delivering lines
at a regular vocal tone or even shouting
them
if you think sterling is in here oh
let's let's do this let's let's drop the
join link join link for
charles and his wife or let's just say
you know
for the wife
for the wife or the wife so charles
there's a joy link for your wife she can
have a word with chart with uh sterling
right now
do you have a response for uh mr hill
she hasn't really elaborated why i'm an
idiot
why do you think
i don't really know look maybe maybe she
doesn't like the idea of me telling her
husband that he might be able to have
another woman in the bedroom with him
aha
it's entirely possible that might have
set her off that could be it
you